well there was a con congressional
committee hearing on abortion yesterday
um i'm going to play a few of these
clips and we'll start with this this is
a pro-abortion activist named amy um
rmb meaty we'll call her being
questioned on the exact difference
between a born child and an unborn child
and uh
kind of going through the process here
you know starting with uh an adult
then going all the way down
to the moment of
birth you know and uh and then you stop
the tape right there at the moment of
birth there's a baby there's a human
being now rewind the clock another five
seconds
what changes isn't that still
whatever that being was
at the moment of birth
was it not that five seconds earlier
that's the that's the line of
questioning here and let's see how it
goes
so so abortion should be allowed then by
your definition for any reason for any
purpose at any stage right
i trust people to make decisions about
their body and then when relevant i
think that they need to consult their
medical
practitioners okay and not if it is
listen let me just ask you this question
if it is not lawful and morally
acceptable to take the life of a
ten-year-old child i assume you agree
with that right that would be wrong
correct
i believe that okay and a two-year-old
child same thing that would be murder we
would all agree that's wrong then what
is the principal distinction between the
human being that is two years old or
nine months old or one week old or an
hour old than one that is eight inches
further up the birth canal in the uterus
what's the difference why is it okay in
the latter case and not the former cases
i trust people to determine what to do
with their own body
full stop
oh that's it sorry she said full stop at
the end so that's that
she wins so all you got you could say
something completely stupid and uh that
doesn't make it but as long as you say
full stop at the end
full stop
see i just did it so it doesn't matter
like whatever you said just say full
stop and you win the argument little
known
fact but you can't she can't answer the
question as always with the
pro-abortion people they can't answer
the most basic questions about their
position and it's a very good question
as was posed there what is the principle
distinction between the child
immediately after birth and immediately
before
did you notice how she she she
was even hesitant
to affirm that it would be wrong to kill
a ten-year-old child
there was that there was like a very
noticeable very loud moment of a pause a
moment of silence there hesitation
when she was asked well clearly killing
a ten-year-old child we all agree there
was this pause
i believe that yeah i believe that's
wrong
oh good well okay glad we're on the same
page with that at least
though probably not for very long
because
there is no principal distinction that
is actually the answer and so whatever
argument you make
for killing the baby five seconds before
the baby is born
um that argument would apply to a child
at any stage
alone
especially in the earliest months right
after birth because the child
you know you could try to
hinge your whole argument on
the fact that the child in the womb is
entirely dependent on their mother for
survival
which is true but that doesn't do that
doesn't change the fact that it's still
a human being
and if your moral worth and your legal
rights
depend on you not being dependent upon
others for survival well then i got bad
news for people on welfare
right
i've got bad news for a lot of people in
this country who are dependent on others
for survival but especially newborn
babies
who in many ways are
you know more not many ways in fact in
almost every way are more demanding of
their mother's time and attention and
and
body and very life
than the child was in the womb
uh now this same activist was also asked
whether men can become pregnant
and she's not a biologist as far as i
know but she still actually had an
answer to this question let's listen
what do you say a woman is
i believe that everyone can identify for
themselves
okay
um
do you believe then that men can become
pregnant and have abortions
yes
i mean she has no choice but to say that
of course but she has no definition of
woman
men can become pregnant
these are these are statements now being
made in congressional hearings on the
record
i also i loved here's a moment that i
that i really like this is kind of
reversing the roles here
now it's a pro-life person testifying
and a pro-abortion
uh politician questioning her
and the pro-life person look at her name
in a second i don't remember her name
but she she does something here that i
that i'm i'm very glad she does she
makes up she makes a point
she kind of has a rebuttal that's very
simple but i'm i'm happy that she did it
because i had exactly the effect
that it was destined to have let's watch
this
is candidly
and openly calling for a nationwide
ban on all abortions with no exceptions
for rape
or incest
and if i've got that wrong i would
invite miss foster to correct me
do i have a wrong yes or no
if we added rape and incest exceptions
would you vote for it
okay
i reclaim my time of course
there we go perfect that was catherine
glenn foster was the woman being
questioned there by representative jamie
raskin
and uh i'm so glad she responded that
way
because that's exactly what you should
do
it's when when the
when the pro-abortion people go on and
on about there's no exceptions for rape
and incest yeah but would it matter to
you if there was
okay let's say that we made the
exception would you would you vote for
would make any difference to you at all
well i i i reclaim my time
no response because because of course
the answer is it doesn't make a
difference to them
they they wouldn't make any exception
they don't believe in exceptions anyway
it's like so it doesn't matter it's an
irrelevant point
so that's why you already this is so
often the case with the left when
they're when you're engaging with the
left
um
there are so many moves that they make
where if you engage then you've already
lost so once they start going on about
should there be exceptions for rape and
incest when you engage with that
you lose
because that's all they want to talk
about
um
that's why the correct answer is but
what does that do with anything
would would it make a difference to you
no it wouldn't okay well let's move on
then why are we even talking about it
they do the same damn thing they do they
just say the same thing kind of thing on
every topic but they do the same things
of course on gender with transgenderism
well there are
there are people who are who are
intersex and it could appear to be a man
but really this is a woman because of
the sexual you know deformities and
okay well
are you saying that a person who identif
a man who identifies as a woman but is
not intersex doesn't count as a woman
well no i'm not saying that okay well
why are you talking about intersex what
does it do with anything
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content